donald trump did deliver what i believe
we can safely call his final
address as president of the united
states yesterday it's basically an
unrecognizable person it it this is not
a trump we have ever seen before
uh it's not like trump uh
has been this person we saw yesterday
for the last four years but was
pretending to be somebody else
i believe that the trump we saw
yesterday is a fake trump
it is a desperate trump and trump's
speech yesterday
is a desperate plea for mercy trump is
isolated
furious abandoned by many republicans
banned from a number of social media
accounts
and he sat in the oval office yesterday
and recorded what he hopes is a speech
that will save him that will take the
pressure off
in terms of a possible impeachment
conviction in the senate
he is attempting to dial down the
possibility of future investigations
into his endless wrongdoing
let's take a look at it my fellow
americans
i want to speak to you tonight about the
troubling events
of the past week as i have said the
incursion of the u.s capitol
struck at the very heart of our republic
it angered and appalled millions of
americans
across the political spectrum
i want to be very clear i unequivocally
condemned the violence that we saw last
week
violence and vandalism have absolutely
no place in our country
and no place in our movement making
america great again has always been
about defending
the rule of law so a unifying and
empathetic trump right give me a break
guys
no one who has been paying attention for
the last really now
five plus years is falling for this this
is trump having
a speech on a prompter shoved in front
of him and being told
this is what you need to say to maybe
save yourself
from some of what is unlike what is
likely to be coming
and of course trump now the unifier
around the riots he caused through his
two months of election lies
and a speech saying let's go to the
capitol right now
now of course the maga movement has
never been about defending the rule of
law they say that
but even before being a president trump
would tell his supporters
that if they are rough with protesters
at his rallies
and they get arrested and charged he'll
pay their legal fees now as we'll find
out on the bonus show today
trump doesn't pay anybody's legal fees
he's not even paying his own
but we'll get to that later let's get to
more of yesterday's bizarre statement
from trump
mob violence goes against everything i
believe in
and everything our movement stands for
no true supporter of mind could ever
endorse
political violence no true supporter of
mine could ever disrespect
law enforcement or our great american
flag
no true supporter of mine could ever
threaten or harass
their fellow americans if you do any of
these things
you are not supporting our movement you
are attacking it
and you are attacking our country we
cannot tolerate it
tragically over the course of the past
year
made so difficult because of covet 19.
trump caused the mob violence
his supporters led a mob it's sort of a
no true scotsman situation if anyone
rioted then by definition they couldn't
have been my supporters well
sir they had trump hats and trump shirts
and trump flags when they broke in and
when they gave interviews they said they
were for trump
and when they posted to social media
they said they were for trump yeah but
they weren't
true supporters of mine indefeasible
right it's a closed loop
you can't uh you can't break it as we
talked about last week
trump also by the way mentioned covet 19
there
now trump of course has disastrously
mishandled the virus
so everything about this speech is just
fantasy world
looney tunes here's another uniting
message from this new trump
whether you are on the right or on the
left
a democrat or a republican
there is never a justification for
violence
no excuses no exceptions
america is a nation of laws
those who engaged in the attacks last
week
will be brought to justice now i am
asking everyone who has
ever believed in our agenda to be
thinking of ways to ease tensions
calm tempers and help to promote peace
in our country now some people might
hear trump say everyone will be brought
to justice and they'll react by saying
wow trump's doing the right thing
he's being tough on the rioters that
really takes
takes some uh strength trump never
cared about the rioters here's what
people have to understand
when they were rioting trump was pleased
initially we know he was liking it and
he liked how it delayed the electoral
vote count
he never cared about the rioters as
people he never cared about the rioters
as his voters or supporters it just was
useful to his political goals then trump
noticed that the writers looked low
class
that's these are the reports we got
multiple reports about that
trump still didn't care about them as
people he just cared about how they made
him look and low-class rioters made
trump look bad remember
trump has spent his entire life trying
to stay away from people
like most of his supporters at his golf
clubs and at his high-rise apartments
and then the rioters now were getting
arrested
and it led to trump's impeachment so
trump denounces them and says they're
not my true supporters and they're going
to be persecuted
uh prosecuted to the fullest extent of
the law he's not abandoning anyone in so
far as he was never actually with them
they were always merely political tools
and now he's using this to try to get
points for lowering the temperature but
it's much too late to matter
let's watch a little bit more donald
trump saying don't do any more riots
please
there has been reporting that additional
demonstrations are being planned
in the coming days both here in
washington
and across the country i have been
briefed by the u.s secret service
on the potential threats every american
deserves to have their voice heard
in a respectful and peaceful way that is
your first
amendment right but i cannot emphasize
that there must be no violence no law
breaking
and no vandalism of any kind everyone
must follow our laws
and obey the instructions of law
enforcement
i have directed federal agencies to use
all
necessary resources to maintain order
in washington dc we are bringing in
thousands of national guard members
to secure the city and ensure that a
transition
can occur safely and without incident so
there it is
trump sending a message no more riots
now trump can't get out of this without
doing
some of his typical routines so here
trump goes after social media platforms
for banning him as assaults on free
speech
i also want to say a few words about the
unprecedented assault
on free speech we have seen in recent
days
these are tense and difficult times the
efforts to censor
cancel and blacklist our fellow citizens
are wrong and they are dangerous
what is needed now is for us to listen
to one another
not to silence one another
all of us can choose by our actions
to rise above the rancor and find common
ground and
shared purpose we must focus on
advancing the interests of the whole
nation
delivering the miracle vaccines
defeating the pandemic rebuilding the
economy
protecting our national security and
upholding
the rule of law now of course the social
media stuff is not a free speech issue
i'm not going to get into into that
again we've gone over that ad nauseam
uh and of course this donald trump
we've never seen this trump because he
doesn't exist this isn't
real trump the real guy is the guy he
has plainly been
in public which matches the guy he's
plainly been
in private that's the real trump the
five-minute trump we saw yesterday
is just a pathetic desperate attempt to
save himself
and get some mercy so that republicans
when the impeachment trial starts can
say listen
trump lowered the temperature he dialed
it down we're not going to vote to
convict that's the goal and one more
thing
if this would have been trump all along
it would have been fake
but he would have gotten re-elected if
with the virus trump had done
that and said this is a tough time let's
listen to the doctors
no mass anti-mass protest just listen to
the doctors
way fewer people would have died and
trump would have sailed to re-election
there
would have been no riot and trump would
be getting another four years too little
too late from fake trump let me know
your reaction i'm on twitter at d
pacman so it's a new year and for
many people that means new goals around
getting fit
or losing weight and if part of that for
you
involves a low carb or ketogenic diet
then i have something you will want to
check out it's called
so keto licious and they're giving you
twenty percent off
soaky delicious has perfected ketogenic
crusts for baking your favorite foods
they make a delicious keto dessert crust
which comes in a chocolate
and vanilla flavor and it's perfect for
making things like pies they also have a
premium keto pizza crust which i've been
using at home to make pizzas and it's
great
it is great to go right out of the
freezer
and when you cook it it doesn't fall
apart like a lot of other low carb
crusts do
it's high fat which is perfect for keto
grain free gluten free no soy or
additives or
preservatives or fillers but most
importantly
they just taste great i can tell you
first hand just go to davidpakman.com
pizza the link is underneath this video
and they'll give you 20
off your entire order when you use the
coupon code pacman